so let's define mathematical framework
for how to do this we define skew of K
as simply the number of G - number of
see in the first K new clea ties of the
genome and skew diagram is simply Plaut
showing skew of cake against K now let's
construct skew diagram for the e.coli
genome it looks beautifully where do you
send is the origin of replication
Nikolai's something that we almost had
no hope to find of course it's at the
point where it was decreasing concern
suddenly start increasing which is here
we found the replication origin in
vehicle ID and now let's try to find
frequent word in this origin and
hopefully we will find DNA a box in this
way
well after we run our frequent words
problem unfortunately it turns out there
are no frequent words that appear even 3
times in this replication origin which
means that we failed there are many
reasons while we may fail maybe origin
of replication is derived from skew
diagram doesn't show precisely to the
area where we want to see or maybe just
maybe we don't have a good grip on how
hidden messages in E coli origin look
like should we give up let's try to
proceed further and figure out what else
can be done and when we were looking for
frequent words via our view of frequent
words was very naive we assume that
frequent words are simply Kaymer but
maybe hidden messages that cell uses to
initiator applications are more elusive
more subtle
let's look at this original for
application in Vibrio cholera and try to
see maybe there is something else we
already found six 9-mer in this region
but maybe just maybe there is something
else that deserves our attention and if
you look carefully there then you will
see that in addition to this six hidden
messages there are two more there are
actually two nightmares that look almost
like canonical nightmares they differ
just in a single mutation and they also
represent dnaa boxes because DNA can
bind not only to the perfect nightmare
but to different variation in this of
this nightmare so to find this type of
more elusive frequent words we need to
solve frequent words with mismatches
problem when the input is string text
and integers K and D in what if we want
to find all most frequent k-mers with
these at most D mismatches in the text
and finally after we've done this and
run how frequent worked with mismatches
problem we do find somewhat more elusive
frequent words in ecology gnome and they
turn out to be indeed real dnaa boxes in
nikolai now what I described is a very
idealistic view of how your application
can be found in reality some bacteria
have fewer dnaa boxes and our frequent
words algorithm won't work for finding
them terminus of replication is often
not located directly opposite to the
origin of replication and the skew
diagram is often more complex than in
the case of E coli